april what's going on so i've been in a
relationship since may
with a really wonderful guy who treats
me well
and who has a lot of the qualities i
desire and a partner
but i just don't feel like i'm starting
to fall in love with him yet
and it's almost like when he tries to
get closer
i feel the urge to start to pull away
and i guess that just scares me because
looking back on
past relationships like i realized that
every time that i've been in love it's
always
been what's a really unhealthy partner
and when i find
a man who would be suitable for me it's
almost like i have a tendency to either
put him in the friend zone
or i just can't develop feelings for him
and i just don't know how to fix this
sure so a couple of quick questions in
do you have any relational abuse in the
past
or just guys that cheat on you do you
have guys that are have been awful
or ugly you have childhood abuse like
give me a quick primer
um so for example my last relationship
um the person
had a problem with alcohol and really
only wanted to see me when he was
drinking
and he ended up cheating on me while we
were
dating but as far as my my childhood
uh my older brother has cerebral palsy
and so
my past wasn't abusive it was just my
parents really didn't notice me because
they were
really focused on my brother and his
needs for most of my life and so i was
always just very like self-sufficient
and was trying to meet my own needs
sure very much childhood so understand
this
trauma works two ways one is
what i would call affirmative trauma
someone's alcoholic
they're abusive to you they hit you they
yell you see a car wreck you see
somebody get shot
those are affirmative traumas
there's also neglect traumas
where people don't give you what you
should have had
which is connection and value and high
touch and daddy's looking at their
daughters
on a regular basis in the eye and saying
how are you tell me about your dragons
tell me about your princesses tell me
about your baseball
hugging their sons right that's those
are both traumas and your brain
registers both of those as there is a
problem in a relationship that is my
fault and i've got to fix it
it also logs in and i hate using
computer metaphors it's the only one i
can come up with on top of my head right
now
it begins to log in relationships hurt
there is pain here and it's begin
scanning your environment for the rest
of your life for somebody that's going
to hurt you
and so two things emerge from that sort
of
from that childhood number one
other people are more important than you
and it's your job to make sure you plug
into others
and number two people hurt and so when
somebody who is
good and somebody who is right and
somebody who is noble
tries to plug into you your brain sounds
the alarms
it goes off danger danger will robinson
look out
run right yes exactly
and so you think you're only worth an
alcoholic idiot
and that's a lie and now you're looking
at this other dude
do you do you find him attractive would
you love to just
smooch him and smooth like so what
happens you lean in to give him a kiss
what happens
um i just feel really uncomfortable i
think with any sort of like physical
closeness
or if he wants to spend a lot of time
together it's almost like
i just i just want to pull away for some
reason so is he annoying or is this on
you
is he unattractive does he not shave
does he not brush his teeth
or is this go ahead
yeah he's very attractive and honestly
he has like
all the qualities that i would want and
a future husband like i could see a
future with him
it's just the the feelings aren't there
yet i guess
i don't understand what you mean when
you say the feelings aren't there yet
what does that mean
just the feeling of like in loveness and
that spark and like wanting to be with
him all the time like when i
hang out with him it's almost like it's
a chore that i have to do to let someone
else into my life
and it's almost like i'm more
comfortable just like being alone there
you go
and is that a learned behavior is that
something you've experienced your whole
life
i mean you talked about when you were a
kid you had to be self-sufficient from a
young age
yeah yeah i moved out when i was um 17
and pretty much been on my own since
have you ever been in love this spark
that you're craving or are you
watching hollywood videos and wanting
that
no i was in love with the previous guy
who
had the problem with alcohol and i think
it may have been
because he needed me and it kind of gave
me like a sense of worth there you go
so what you're gonna have to do is
you're gonna have to come to the
realization
that you are worth being loved
not you are only have value when you fix
other people
you only have value when you make sure
everyone else is okay
but that you have value just because and
somebody else
has the right to love you the way that
you want to love other people
and the the
the the broad picture here is a fear of
intimacy
right it's this fear of getting close to
somebody because they're going to hurt
me
that i have no value that i'm not worth
it right so here's a couple of things i
can
i can tell you um you've got to ask
yourself
do you want to love him and so this big
clouds and rainbows and marshmallows all
of that the lightning bolts and all that
it doesn't happen for everybody and it
happens differently for other people
and i know hollywood so bad wants us to
believe that's the way it works it
doesn't always work that way some people
it does and they are lucky and they are
blessed and that's awesome
um in my house it happened that way for
my wife and not for me
she she'll tell you i looked at you i
was playing a
i was singing a song at some show and
she said that's the guy
that's it and she was done
like literally done and it took me years
to um recognize oh she's the one for me
right she is the one i want to dedicate
my entire life to it works
different for people and so you i want
you to look
look at it moving forward this way
not as love as a lightning bolt love is
a quote unquote feeling
but that love is going to become a skill
love
and intimacy are going to become skills
that you need to learn
okay things you're going to have to
practice
and things you have to be vulnerable
about with other people
okay there's a couple of great books out
there i'll recommend one of them here
let's talk for a second just globally
and this isn't just for april this is to
everybody i want to talk for a second
about this idea this fear of intimacy
okay fear of intimacy it's a broad
psychological term that describes people
who are afraid of being in close
relationships
and this can be a challenge even in
long-term relationships just because
you've been married a long time
having regular sex have a few kids
doesn't mean there's
not major intimacy issues and we often
think intimacy is just about sex it's
just about holding hands and kissing
not all intimacy is sexual it can also
be emotional
spiritual intellectual experiential
right
we have the same interests we have the
same experiences
right it's this idea of intimacy
is being fully known can i be completely
honest about the thoughts in my head can
i be completely honest about
my actions what i've done
and here's where it gets even deeper can
i be completely honest about what has
happened to me
can i talk about my hurts right so can i
talk about what's in my head
my thoughts and my feelings can i just
put them out there without being judged
without me giving without being given
advice can i talk about the things i've
done
here's some stupid stuff i said when i
was in high school here's somebody i
hooked up with when i was in college
here's somebody fill in the blank can i
talk about the things i did at work that
i wish i hadn't done
whatever it happens to be do i have a
safe place where i can come home and put
that down
and can i talk about people who've hurt
me
and if you're listening to this and you
know what i'm talking about it feels
like
doors just one door and then another
layer and then another layer
right being afraid of intimacy doesn't
mean you don't want to be intimate just
like april just like you're saying
it doesn't mean you don't want it it
just it might look like indifference
coldness or anger but the person who
fears intimacy
usually desperately longs for it and
you've heard me talk over and over and
over about
intimacy loneliness a lack of intimacy
and loneliness
are killing us as a country killing us
individually it's destroying our bodies
because our bodies crave connection
right a couple of causes of fear of
intimacy
comes from being hurt by others it's
complex but it stems from
attachment issues it can come from
unstable unpredictable childhoods
think of think of this line and tattoo
it on your heart childhood biology
becomes our adult biography a few
situations as we talked about with april
parent illness brother and sister
illness right
it's this loss of innocence at a young
age before you understand fully what's
going on
parent neglect abuse parent substance
abuse loss of a parent codependency
enmeshed families unresolved grief
here's the deal in april this is
specific for you but it's also for
everybody
relationships equal risk always
relationships are a risk i don't care if
you've been married for 30 years
if you've got secrets you haven't told
you know it's because it's a risk
and you're afraid that that person's
going to hurt you they're going to
weaponize what your secrets are
you're afraid that they're going to tell
you oh yeah well you should just
fill in the blank as though you're an
idiot
relationship is a risk and when you've
seen the other side of risk
your brain and your body try to protect
you from getting hurt again
right so here's how to overcome the fear
of intimacy number one april
here's what i want you to do whenever
that guy
this beautiful guy who treats you well
he's a good person
whenever he leans over to hold your hand
and you're you're like ah
try this thank your brain for trying to
protect you it's just doing its job
i want you to exhale i want you to say
thank you but i'm good now this guy's
safe
thank your shortness of breath think
your heart rate
thank your body for protecting you if
you have a fear of intimacy and you know
you are safe
and you want to get close to somebody
think your physical response
and then i want you to decide what you
really want
you cannot have meaningful and deep
relationships without
intimacy without being able to say
here's what i'm thinking here's what
i've thought here's what i've done
here's who hurt me and you can't be
intimate if you can't receive that from
other people
accept that intimacy equals risk and
understand the rewards of intimacy
are so worth it and you're going to get
hurt in relationships you just are
i want you to embrace vulnerability and
own the risk
being close with people is scary because
it involves vulnerability and
vulnerability is when you expose
yourself to the possibility of being
hurt
and if you love somebody you will be
hurt period at the end of that sentence
exclamation point into that sentence
you'll be hurt
you can read daring greatly by brene
brown if you want to really get into
sexuality and intimacy you can read a
book called come as you are by emily
nagoski
it's probably the best book i've ever
read on sex it's not a faith-based book
it is
a science book written for dumb people
like me
she does a great job of just distilling
things down in a very simple way
but she talks a lot about this falseness
of sex being a drive and intimacy being
something other than something you learn
and you practice
and then go for little wins exposure
they call it in the psychology
world try holding hands try being honest
ask for patience try writing letters or
gently leaning in let intimacy come
through letter writing where there's a
little bit of distance not through text
messages
but through letter writing where there's
some distance some space
but you're being vulnerable you're
beginning to expose your thoughts right
when your physical alarms no off know
that you're not going to die
you're going to be okay and your
feelings are okay
they're just trying to protect you and
then also
if you really have problems connecting
with other
people you know you've got to go see a
mental health professional if you have a
pattern of a fear of intimacy
if you've got deep-rooted things april
you're telling me this stuff's been
around since my childhood
you may need to get with somebody who
will hold you accountable with a
professional a mental health
professional hold you accountable give
you some things to try and practice
this is not a forever relationship
you're going to learn some new skills
it's like getting a batting coach except
you're going to get an intimacy coach or
a love coach or a relationship coach
right
make an appointment to talk with a
therapist or counselor listen to me
april and to everyone struggling with
intimacy
men women beautiful people people who
don't believe they're beautiful
everybody you are worth
a relationship you're worth being
connected you're worth being loved
you're worth
all of it